hi I'm now Lauren and this is a wired
autocomplete interview are these
actually the first questions that come
up is niall horan a tenner uh I don't
think I'm out of puberty yet so I've got
quite the range is Niall Horan
colorblind not Horan is colorblind how
many people know this one struggle
sometimes with shades of green and
yellow that are close to each other I've
been caught out and a few times where
people are gonna even put a blade like
yeah didn't know I was won't be able to
fire a plane apparently it's Niall Horan
left-handed Niall Horan's left-handed
Ned horn right to his left hand but I
play golf right-handed I play guitar
right-handed I'm left-footed as well
when I play soccer it's not Horan
related to Helen and we've been getting
this for years myself and mr. generous
we're not related and I wish is Niall
Horan a country singer I'm not a country
singer but I have one type one country
sounding song that my friend Mara Mara
sings army called see him blind
is Niall Horan and small force I hope
you trying to say I'm not but I did
write a song that was the soundtrack to
the movie small foot last one in this
one is null horn a natural brunette
Niall Horan is a natural brunette died
my start dye my hair blonde highlights
was about 12 or 13 I realized that when
you get to a certain age you probably
shouldn't have highlights anyway because
that makes you look like you're clinging
on to your youth on to the next one
Thank You shin right how to meet Niall
Horan is that question passing on the
street in a pub and although I've taken
you won't see me at a pub for October as
I've taken the month of October off
alcohol gigs meet and greets all the
great places was Niall Horan part of One
Direction Niall Horan was part of one
direction didn't look a little bit
looked at me more blonde and smaller
what color are Niall Horan's eyes
I think they're like blue with tinges of
yellow he green where is Niall Horan
from nod horn is from Mullingar small
little town about an hour west of Dublin
in Ireland where does Niall Horan live
Google Maps generally London and Los
Angeles when was Niall Horan born time I
actually didn't know this until weirdly
a one day I was sitting on Twitter and
it was my birthday and I was looking at
tweets and basically someone had my
birth cert kind of it was like man Horan
was born 835 on a Monday morning
September the 13th I was like what and
then I asked me woman they were right
when is Niall horn releasing new music
Niall Horan has a brand new single right
now it's called nice to meet you
cuz it is nice to meet you got an album
next year as well for those who
listening on for the next one
what is Niall Horan's blood type no idea
what is Niall Horan's nickname one of my
mates called me large for a reason I
can't tell you neither just kind my name
with ER on the end of it is what a lot
of people call me really
I've always been sad and never really
had a strong nickname I would like that
could have been my stage name what does
no Lauren smell like right now it's
chicken because I've just eaten I've
heard a lot of people say that I smell
great Louis Capaldi said recently my
hair smells good cuz he spends a lot of
time smelling my head when I see him
which is really strange well is Niall
Horan's Slowhand song about quite sexy
stuff getting it on that's pretty much
it
what was a Niall Horan's imaginary
friend called I don't think I had one
how is Niall Horan right now a night
horns great neither the horn is doing an
interview he's having a great time
you're answering some questions in New
York for the first time in a while got a
new song now raring to go thanks for
asking appreciate it how to get Niall
Horan to know it's you on Twitter ask a
question like the above and every day a
question I'm a normal guy with an
abnormal
job how did Niall Horan become famous
nyle horn audition for a TV show called
The X Factor in the UK failed and then
got put into a band with four others
that failed damn we were ended up in a
band called One Direction how to draw
Niall Horan step-by-step there's enough
talented people out there don't know how
to draw and I'm just gonna leave you to
do that yourselves how many siblings is
Niall Horan home at one older brother 32
Greg this is next one
what is Niall Horan's favourite animal
I like lions I did a safari a few years
ago and watching a lion walking around
in the wild and doing its job is really
impressive what does Niall Horan order
at Nando's how long have we got like who
could be here well I do a double
breasted chicken wrap medium with some
alumina in it Perry paraphrase with
Peres neighs what is Niall Horan's
middle name Niall james horan derived
from my granddad's name which was Seamus
what hospital was an island born in
Niall Horan was born in the mana gar
General Hospital and in my hometown in
Wollongong what is Niall Horan's
favorite drink I absolutely love Guiness
yes we are Irish and we live up to every
single stereotype Guinness is my
favourite sweet nectar I don't even want
to talk about it gets me emotional worth
guitar this Niall Horan play I just got
myself a new Fender Telecaster from 1964
and it looks kind of Springsteen esque
who is now the Horan's
best friend his name is Sean Mulholland
otherwise known as Molly when schooled
together since we were kids you now move
to LA and lives with me for his own job
he's not following me around the world
like some hang around who doesn't know
the Horan support I support a team
called Derby County it's painful and
I'll start to tear up after a while we
haven't been in the Premier
League in years and it's getting a
little bit sad otherwise I support
Chelsea who does niall horan look like
when I was younger people used to say I
look like the kid from Stuart little
with the glasses Stuart now I get Alan
leach who is an Irish guy and he's in
Downton Abbey I have to say we do
actually really look like each other I
mean he's known her handsome Irishman
you note the use of another who did
Niall Horan right this turnabout based
on my hometown slash young love from
that town first like girlfriend or what
I thought was a girlfriend and every
time I passed that girl in the pub and
she's moved on with her life makes you
reflect and be nostalgic so that's what
that was about
here we go another one in the great
words of dj khaled those Niall Horan
speak Spanish night horn does not speak
Spanish
does Niall Horan like Harry Potter I
could not gonna lie i wasin for a long
time and then Warner Brothers opened up
the set to the public in London and I
lived nearby and I went to the set after
I seen the set I went home and watched
all the movies back to back what house
would I be in Gryffindor all day long I
take me and run woulda went for a few
beers together we would have sneaked out
over the wall at the school I tear me
and run would have been good friends in
Gryffindor there's Niall Horan wear
contacts no I don't wear contacts and I
kind of used to do this thing for style
where I used to wear like clear lens
glasses and then that obviously caught
up on me because I was wondering why I
couldn't really see like the score of a
football match on a TV are see you where
the camera is but then I went and got an
eye test and apparently I've got one eye
weaker dind't ER and I wear I wear them
for driving and watching TV like a 50
year old man there's not Horan have
asthma I did when I was a kid
little just a little bit nothing too
crazy I don't know there's neither Horan
have a tattoo not a zero tattoos I'm not
craving it there's order things I would
like to do with my money and my time
onto the final board here we go is Niall
Horan going on tour nod horn will be
going on tour I've noticed that for the
last 20 minutes I've been speaking in
the third person
like he's not here I yeah I am going
onto her back to me and more about him
more about me he's not a in a
soccer player
part time we call it football America
like the rest of the world follow us
please don't be that ignorant you're the
only ones that say soccer okay
get with it did my Lauren have braces I
have braces for two years and and took
them off on your men to wear a retainer
for a while and I didn't so these are
gone and my bottom half are gone a
little bit funky so I've recently just
got Invisalign to help me but yes I did
have braces and they looked at
horrendous where did Niall Horan record
flicker I recorded Flickr studio in LA
and it was an unbelievable experience
full live band in a famous studio
watching my songs come to life was
pretty cool
we had to replicate the sadness when I
came to recording so we were very
delicate and gentle and it was lovely
strings and Shania Twain was there yes I
love that one well the Horan fold for
you can we have a conversation first
maybe I'll probably fall really easily
anywhere so yeah this is the answer to
that I've learned today that people
really do like to dig in and learn stuff
about you it's a simple stuff the
everyday stuff that you would ask do you
wear contacts that's what they have to
Google to find that so far about me
we're very nosy
[Laughter]